[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy el programa
feminista de France 24 se cumplen Ya
seis meses desde la muerte de la joven
Maxi de 22 años tras ser capturada y
violentada por la policía de la moral
acusada de usar mal el velo islámico su
caso que no ha sido objeto de Justicia
hasta el momento
mostró una vez más que elegí ya es a su
vez una muestra de identidad cultural un
signo de opresión y un objeto de
discriminación la muerte de aminia ha
causado protestas masivas miles de
detenciones y más de 500 fallecidos pero
medio año después la movilización social
se ha desgastado que les queda a las
mujeres
para reflexionar sobre este tema está en
ella soy Ana Beltrán ella es portavoz
del movimiento mujer vida y Libertad Ana
bienvenida ella soy de France 24
Hola buenas tardes este movimiento que
usted representa es muy importante
porque nos habla de una causa de
Derechos Humanos después del
fallecimiento de amini y de muchas antes
de ella Pero por otro lado esta misma
semana el jefe del poder judicial de
Irán anunció que 22.000 personas
detenidas en las protestas contra el
régimen fueron indultadas Usted qué
opina de estos anuncios respecto al
desgaste de las protestas
Muchas gracias por invitarme
bueno como bien lo dijiste hace Ya seis
meses hoy justamente que más a mini
perdió la vida tras haber sido asesinada
a manos del régimen islámico no de Irán
seis meses en los cuales la población
era ni de Irán y de su Dios por en el
mundo entero ha sido ha estado ha estado
luchando contra este régimen que no ha
hecho ni Un paso atrás frente a la a la
movilización
[Música]
lo que sí sabemos ahora
dentro de la población iraní es que
efectivamente todos tienen una una sola
voz y una sola voluntad en un cambio
radical de régimen actual con lo cual lo
que necesitan son efectivamente más en
libertad más
derechos bueno los Derechos Humanos los
más básicos de hecho y y bueno no
necesitan unas pocas reformas
se ha demostrado en el pasado de los 44
años de este régimen que este régimen ha
ido en gobernando tras la mentira
Entonces estamos ahora esperando este
cambio de régimen radical y no poniendo
nuestras esperanzas en en anuncios así
sin embargo no se ve que haya un cambio
en el panorama al menos Próximamente
Entonces por un Pues el gobierno iraní
no admite su responsabilidad en este
crimen de Max a mini que aún no ha sido
aclarado de manera oficial lo que
sabemos es apenas la línea de tiempo de
lo que sucedió con ella y por otro lado
anuncia indultos y suaviza un poco las
medidas de de represión en las calles
contra las mujeres y contra el uso del
velo islámico pero no hay anuncios
contundentes en el sentido de una vida
libre de violencias para las mujeres
iraníes En qué edad se ha transformado
entonces la protesta En estos seis meses
y para dónde va el movimiento
efectivamente este panorama ha
evolucionado bastante durante estos seis
meses no empezó tras la muerte de masa
con una gran movilización dentro de Irán
y fuera de Irán que ha sido reprimida
muy fuertemente como bien lo lo se ha
dicho Ahora hay más de 20.000 personas
encarceladas desde hace ahora seis meses
y más de 500 personas han perdido la
vida
con lo cual esta represión fuerte
efectivamente lo que ha llegado lo que
ha logrado el gobierno el régimen
islámico de Irán es poder
apaciguar o callar digamos la calle
sin embargo estamos ahora en una
situación de calma tensa donde no se ha
terminado la crisis y que todavía hay y
continuarán habiendo un rechazo de
régimen claro y mientras tanto las
organizaciones activistas y de derechos
humanos tienen la tarea de lidiar con el
uso del como nos reconciliamos o con
esta prenda tradicional que fuera de los
Países Árabes ese común verla como un
objeto de discriminación entonces
mujeres que defienden el uso del llave
son atacadas precisamente por eso
mientras que dentro del país hay una
lucha por los derechos humanos y las
mujeres buscan que no sea una
obligatoriedad de utilizarlo en la vía
pública porque básicamente desaparecen
como seres individuales y con una
personalidad
y Libertad Pero por otro lado pues
también está este factor cultural no al
final la discusión en torno al en qué va
a quedar
vale hay que Resaltar una cosa esta
lucha no es una lucha contra
contra ni el islam y el es una lucha
para el derecho a decidir y elegir
libremente lo que la gente puede llevar
o no
con lo cual
Hay personas en que están peleando para
erradicar este régimen que está llevando
el llano O sea que no no es un punto de
debate el debate Aquí está en la
libertad de llevarlo o no
claro y cómo Debería ser manejado ese
debate porque no está sobre la mesa no
es algo que se pueda discutir libremente
al menos dentro de Irán por ejemplo
efectivamente bueno debate hay muy poco
dentro del propio gobierno del propio
país No porque la libertad de expresión
es nula y con lo cual pero repito no es
un debate de
de sobre el velo eh está más allá de
esto Obviamente el velo obligatorio es
una cosa pero todos los derechos humanos
y de la mujer obviamente incluidos
dentro es el tema principal de este de
este movimiento
con lo cual hay que englobarlo dentro de
su globalidad este debate dentro de Ilan
no tiene lugar porque no puede haber
lugar para este para tal debate está
la sociedad civil movilizada fuera de
las fronteras de Irán dentro de las
grandes diásporas del mundo
contando con
una persona de personalidades como
actores como deportistas como artistas
movilizados para hacer cambiar la causa
para Bueno a este crimen de se suma
ahora la gran crisis por los
envenenamientos masivos de niñas en
instituciones educativas de Irán
entonces lo que vemos es un ataque casi
que sistemático contra los derechos de
la mujer por eso Quiero preguntarle cuál
es la expectativa que tienen hoy las
niñas y las mujeres en Irán de una vida
libre de violencias qué tanto más se
pueden ver o ejemplos de sus derechos
coartados bajo la influencia del actual
régimen en la República islámica
vale efectivamente este este tema de los
envenenamientos tiene lugar desde hace
ya desde noviembre del año pasado y
casualmente o no están teniendo lugar en
la mayoría del en escuelas de niñas no
de niños sino de niñas vale
porque Bueno todavía no tenemos la luz y
la verdad sobre este tema pero hay una
casualidad es que la el movimiento que
empezó en septiembre del año pasado tuvo
lugar
en gran parte en escuelas de niñas no
que las niñas y las más grandes sean
Opuestos a régimen con lo cual hay la
sociedad iraní ve este movimiento y este
estas conductas estas envenenamientos
como una venganza del propio gobierno
contra la mujer y las niñas niñas
Bueno pues lo que usted nos dice es muy
preocupante Porque además no hay alguna
investigación que pueda asegurar que es
así no no existe la vía para que se
lleve a cabo una investigación de
Derechos Humanos en las condiciones
actuales en Irán y sobre ese tema
también le quería preguntar por el
abogado que representa los derechos
humanos de Max a Mini y de su familia
porque fue también en los últimos días
acusado por el régimen de hacer
propaganda contra el gobierno entonces
pues bajo esas condiciones que podemos
esperar de esta investigación o de esta
defensa de Max examiní y de todos los
casos que hay detrás
efectivamente no se nota una
investigación
con resultados digamos dentro del propio
país de Irán
se dice se anuncian efectivamente unas
investigaciones
pero todavía no tenemos
culpables de estos envenenamientos que
tienen lugar desde hace ya cinco meses
con lo cual no tenemos mucha esperanza
del propio gobierno para hacer sus
propias investigaciones Lo que sí es que
la población iraní tiene mucha esperanza
y en que la la comunidad internacional
política se movilice y que tome una
postura Clara frente a la población
iraní lo que en estos últimos años no ha
habido no ha sido así la postura ha sido
más bien ambigua con lo cual se espera
de entidades Grandes como la Unión
Europea y otros otros grupos de países
que tomen posturas fuertes y con unas
investigaciones efectivamente Y también
con unas con
penalizaciones hacia el propio gobierno
y no hacia el la población en su
globalidad qué es lo que ha estado
sucediendo hasta ahora Ana muchas
gracias a ustedes ya nos quedamos sin
tiempo pero seguro que esta es una
noticia que vamos a tener que seguir
registrando todos los días en nuestros
informativos y sobre todo viendo cómo
avanza esa movilización por la mujer la
vida y la libertad Ana Beltrán
precisamente portavoz de ese movimiento
gracias a usted Muchísimas gracias a
nuestros televidentes como siempre
Gracias por asistir a ellas hoy nos
vemos Próximamente en un nuevo programa
y en France 24 sigan con nosotros
[Música]